Mexico City is absolutely vast
unofficially over 30 million people live
here its boroughs would be cities in
their own right anywhere else in the
world but it's dreadfully poor people
live cheek-by-jowl they need work to get
cash to eat and there's little social
distancing it's a lethal kovat nineteen
mill council workers try to encourage
people to sanitize their hands on a
street corner in its developer one of
the worst hit areas in the city they
have some success the point is this is a
lockdown
I couldn't even cross the road
[Music]
despite government denials the medical
profession here says the disease is
spreading out of control
in some parts of Mexico people don't
think of going to hospital despite being
ill they come to small clinics and patan
when it's too late
dr. Juan Vera's surgery really is the
front in his own PPE advisor from a DIY
shop he offers the only help these
people will likely see he says patients
have died here already too far gone for
intensive care he like all the community
doctors are dealing with this pandemic
as best they can
he says he's scared there's no choice
but to keep working with peravaram a
Coursera otra vez para porque no I
conciencia de fin de aqui no no Tina
conciencia inclusive which I think a no
correct system a que los pacientes que
vienen years ago probably copied now so
no existing no no it says then gobierno
less than 20 meters from the clinic's
front door a huge open market is in full
swing people aren't taking the virus
seriously and there's a social stigma to
being infected so people don't admit it
anyway
this stool owner says he knows of 20
market traders in this one market who
have died ignorance and denial are
dangerous
mr. Larkin okay no Granada Auto spins on
que su problema Politico commercial
mundial we pero realmente here with Oh
muchos disenzo what we have seen is a
failure of the government to impose a
lockdown here and people living in
poverty riddle communities who can't
afford to stay indoors
dr. Lera says the only way his community
will get through this is if they have
already built up natural immunity to
disease that's what he hopes at least
but that's not a lot to go on mr. Ramsay
sky use Mexico City